President Trump is offering to provide
families and survivors quote whatever
you need whatever we can do to ease your
pain one thing he is not offering at
least not yet a new dialogue on guns
something others are demanding of
correspondent Kevin cork is at the White
House tonight good even Kevin hey Brett
the president is expected to visit the
high school there over at Parkland we
haven't quite nailed down the timing on
that visit but obviously once we do
we'll pass that along to you as you
probably know his Resort over at
mar-a-lago is only about 40 miles away
from the site of yesterday's carnage
today he talked about what happened
there yesterday and he told America's
children in particular you are never
alone and you never will be
we mourn for all of those who lost their
lives we comfort the grieving and the
wounded a day after a gunman killed at
least 17 people at a Florida high school
president Trump pledged his
administration would act we are
committed to working with state and
local leaders to help secure our schools
and tackle the difficult issue of mental
health notably the president did not
mention the issue of gun control or new
gun laws during his address to the
nation his remarks today Attorney
General Jeff Sessions stayed on message
saying the Justice Department would
partner with other federal agencies to
study the intersection of mental health
and criminality and violence and to
identify weekend's how we can stop
people before these heinous crimes occur
but for a time Thursday Treasury
secretary Steve minuchin appeared to
veer away from his administration's
orthodoxy on the topic when he said this
personally I think the gun violence it's
a tragedy what we've seen yesterday and
I urged Congress to look at these issues
however later his office clarified the
remarks saying there was no daylight
between him and the president the
administration's focused on the possible
mental state of the shooter rather than
the weapon used in the attack is not new
after a Texas church shooting that
claimed 26 lives the president said this
isn't a gun situation after the Las
Vegas shooter killed 58 and left nearly
900 others injured the president called
the shooter dumb
and a very sick individual the partland
shooting just the latest in a string of
deadly violence to strike America
schoolchildren with more than two dozen
fatal active shooting incidents since
Columbine in 1999 the administration's
apparent emphasis on mental health
rather than guns drew a sharp rebuke
from Connecticut Senator Richard
Blumenthal his state was the site of the
Sandy Hook massacre in 2012 that claimed
26 including 20 children
gun safety legislation than win the
election because people die from this
the Minority Leader is also calling for
more gun violence research to be
conducted by and funded by the federal
government that is something many
Republicans oppose threat kevin cork
live in the north law and kevin thank
you